okay okay I'll look okay yeah great
thank you okay Emily Emily weird you're
up where you from
okay so I grew up in Tacoma Washington
which is just outside of Seattle
Washington
tell me about your family hit both your
parents no my mom was a single mom
growing up and it was pretty hard I had
a lot of issues with seeing my parents
fight my dad lived in Vegas and my dad
was in and out of our lives and always
physically like violent with my mom and
it was really rough cuz I was the only
child and I was alone a lot so my mom
had to go to work and leave me alone and
it was really it was really lonely you
know so but then later on she met my
stepdad and then my stepdad I he came
into my life when I was 8 and him and I
never got along so I had like real
serious issues with men you know not
being accepted like of me since a young
age then it really like threw me off you
know
so it still affects you today yeah
big-time big-time so yeah any any of you
sir um well throughout my whole life
I've had a lot of sexual abuse um it
started when I was a little girl when I
was with my mom I had friends that I was
hanging out with when I was like four
and five and they were being sexually
molested by their stepfather and so they
were coming to hang out with me and they
were also touching me because of showing
like what their father did to them they
were passing it on to me and so I
started touching myself a very young age
like like around five I started like
constantly like touching my you know
taking my underwear off at daycare I was
getting kicked out of daycare I was
always trying to you know touch private
parts and stuff it became really like a
serious problem
my mom's like really embarrassed and I
didn't know what I was doing I remember
not knowing why it was such a big deal
and I would be like touching my you know
what I mean trying to like and I was
having like orgasms like a young age
because I was doing it you know until I
was you know no you know what I mean but
it was like a stress relief and it's
like embarrassing but yeah I would get
in trouble and like spank and stuff but
I had to hide it
you know but I was like a chronic
masturbator when I was younger as though
you know but it's just from sexual abuse
you know and then over time you know
like being so sexually like intrigued
like important and all that stuff I was
always looking for like sexual you know
things to get any like porn and magazine
anything you know and experiences with
people so it led to a lot of rape um
also you know we're falling asleep and
waking up with the wrong people you know
which is kind of like something that I
don't consider like rape a lot and I
never reported because I put myself in
the position so you know but yeah a lot
of a lot of sexual trauma for sure you
know so and when a drug use too many
drug use actually came in later in my
life because I was actually pretty
I thought normal you know until I was 27
and I started using drugs when my
husband had went to jail and I was just
mad and I met a girl that I was and went
to high school with and she was using
meth and we started using meth and I
haven't stopped since and how do you
support yourself now I support myself by
escorting on the streets of Los Angeles
and it's not a totally bad job I've lost
a lot of my connection with my family
though and I have no friends really at
all because girls don't respect me and
men kind of look at me like it's a
little bit lower level you know just as
a sex object but the money I make is
really good and I can support myself and
other people you know and I get it
really fast but the downside there's a
lot of downsides to it
as well but right now that's the only
thing I can really function in and do
I'm a drug addict how much do you make a
night or day right now I'm making like
up to like two to three hundred but I
when I was in my like prime and doing
not so much drugs because right now the
drugs have kind of taken over I'm a
heroin addict and stuff and crystal
addict and before I was so deep into it
I it was making $1,000 a day easy you
know and it was really I was really
proud of myself and excited about having
a pimp in these men that were so into me
because growing up I was really not
attractive I was fat and I was just not
accepted by the boys that I went to high
school with and you know and so when I
started realizing men were kind of
attracted to me when I was older I just
was you know especially with all that
sexual you know like in a curiosity so I
just was you know prostitution became
like a fun thing for me that I was proud
of I felt good that men wanted to pay to
be like around me you know when I didn't
care who they were but they weren't
actually paid to you know be with me so
that made me feel like you know worth
you know so so it's a little bit of a
self-esteem boost and also kind of
undermines yourself right right it's
with your time yeah it's very weird yes
it's like bad days can be really bad
like some days I can have where men are
not like I go up to the to their car or
you know respond to them and they see me
and they're like oh nevermind you know
that King we're like really hurt me you
see you know and that just makes me feel
like [ __ ] or other times when the guys
decide you're awesome you're beautiful
you're so gorgeous you know and I'm just
like yeah but it's like I lived through
what they feel about me you know I don't
have the confidence in myself
you know by myself I have to know what
they're thinking about me and that's how
I feel at that time so yeah yeah I do
right now I've been on and off my whole
career doing it um I've been through a
lot of terrible pimps but right now
hopefully it's good
because usually when I work by myself I
don't make at all the amount of money I
do with the pain but him you know keeps
you on track keeps you doing you know
like when I'm by myself I just get like
20 40 bucks and then I go out and dude
open and you know I I get lazy I don't
do half the [ __ ] it's like when there's
somebody there watching you doing what
you're supposed to do I do it better
because I want to show off anyways and
stuff and I just want to be like look
I'm the cool girl that can bringing all
this money but when I'm by myself I'm
like did you still you're still breaking
him off all the money yeah I give him
everything mm-hmm were there some of the
terrible stories you've had when that my
earlier payments well I had a concussion
because I got my head kicked in really
bad for being out of pocket because I
was telling one of his other girls that
I missed my old like boyfriend out of
his way
out of pocket is when with the whole in
event when you're doing something that
is not okay like there's a list of rules
strict rules like that we follow you
know and if we ever do you know
something that is out of pocket which
means when you're in pocket that means
you're doing the right thing by your
dude you know like not looking there
talking to other men not flirting not
doing anything that can lead up to
something that would be disloyal or you
know like bringing the other but you're
always trying to you know make European
like the better person you don't want to
bring money to another dude or you know
involve anybody else you want to make
that guy the best you know what I mean I
don't know if that makes any sense
but you know but being out of pocket is
seriously it can range from just looking
at another man you know in the eyes -
you know like giving another man money
that's super serious so so you got you a
concussion at one phone yeah I was on
the I was just I was on the ground
scrubbing the floor and he walked in and
I was like you know hey what's up you
know and he came in and was like hey
how's it going
you know like fine and then he just
kicked me hard as her like in my head
and I was at blood coming out my ear and
I had never does the first time I ever
got hit by anybody you know like not
even my ever like the people of
relationships that were boyfriends you
know but this guy kicked me and then he
started like punching me all because I
had told his other hoe that I missed the
guy that I was with prior to him you
know not that I was going back you know
just that I missed him that I'll you
know I had feelings for him you know
because the guy I was with at the time
that kick meet I had no you know
romantic feelings for it was just a work
relationship but because I was saying
that to her she weren't machine ran you
know in my back and told him because she
wanted to look like a better girl-- you
know in front of his eyes bites niching
which is called hoe games it's terrible
but yeah so yeah but I had a concussion
and that was like the beginning of my
beatings and I got started getting beat
a lot after that which is so weird
because I actually was a really in
Pocket ho compared to a lot of other
girls it's just that they would sense my
submissiveness and they thought that a
lot of them that I chose to be with word
that's not good guys at all you know and
they would see the weakness and they
would prey upon it like I remember
waking up to like being like punched and
beaten and stuff and for no reason like
I just made my quota making money all
night and I needed rest and I remember
waking up to getting my ass beat like to
get out of it that sucks that's a
terrible way to wake up you know and you
feel like [ __ ] about you so so and you
don't understand why you're trying to do
everything right and you know this
[ __ ] is you know kicking your
ass so you know so but that's just you
know they're their problems you know but
it's hard for hoes because when we meet
a man that says he's a pimp he's
supposed to be God to us he's supposed
to be like everything we're supposed to
listen to him and he's never supposed to
be wrong so it's us that are always
wrong so if we try to you know tell him
like in a relationship with a man and a
woman a wife and husband the
equal with a pin Minho the hoe is always
the one in the wrong no matter even if
she's right you know what I'm saying so
it sucks when you have a person that
you're working with who is extremely
abusive mental mental illness is
involved you know drug addiction for
them so that's when things can get
really ugly and people can get killed or
go to jail
that experience is with your customers
as well oh yeah yeah definitely
I mean customers are actually usually
better but I have had a lot of yeah bad
experiences but I've learned a lot in
the beginning I went through a lot of
you know stuff that all hos go through
you know learning how to protect
ourselves right like always making sure
they wear condoms because they stride to
not where they it's so crazy how many
guys that are normal men that have wives
and children working you know the
society that are regular people you know
people that you know are doctors lawyers
they have you know families and they
come to me and they want to you know use
a no condom which is called bareback we
call it bareback they don't want they
want to be able to you know like come
inside our like on our bodies and and
you know in our bodies which is like you
know illnesses like AIDS everything you
know what I mean or in our mouths you
know and they think because they're
their excreting something that they're
not gonna get anything you know they're
like immune but it's not how it works
you know what I mean so like it's just
crazy how many like regular normal men
want to give the risk of getting you
know diseases because the girls that
work we're totally not trying to not
work on them you know what I mean so
it's them because they you know don't
want to experience that feeling of
plastic or whatever but it's crazy how
many people have AIDS out here in LA and
it's really scary you know because they
offer you so much more money for no
condoms and stuff but you got to just be
stronger you know so yep children do I
have children I have three three kids
that's the biggest thing I regret in my
life is that I wasn't a good mom you
know cuz like I really love my kids
so much you know where are they I have I
have two of them are with my mom in
Seattle Tacoma area and they are my son
my firstborn is avian he's eight years
old and my daughter ellika who is six
and I have a three year old here in LA
who is his name is archery - and he is
he's half Mexican and yeah I don't get
to see them very much but when I'm with
them it's like great like I'm in like
the happiest person it's just I have
this drug addiction to where like when
I'm with them I can be the best mom but
then when I start to need drugs it's
like things that the drugs come before
them and it's not like I want to put the
drugs before them but it's just I can't
like you know so it's like something I
regret so much because I love them so
much and I don't want them to ever see
the show it's the drugs over them you
know but but where's your third child my
third child here in South Central how
they with so with the parents of my
boyfriend that I had down here I was
with the the father for the last five
years so does your family know you're
okay yeah they don't talk to me anymore
because they don't approve of my
lifestyle you know so and I lost a lot
of kind of world connection with all my
family and it's crazy because we used to
be really close and I just lost my aunt
to brain tumor and it was really hard
cuz I think it's to say goodbye because
she wouldn't um you know what she don't
want to talk to me and nobody wanted to
talk to me because they are very strict
you know they don't believe in drug
addiction and prostitution or any think
I'm like crazy and the fact that is they
think that I am doing this because I
choose to do it like every day I wake up
and I'm like my family or this you know
what I mean like really I would choose
my family
my addiction is something that is so
strong right now
that it takes over you know president
over my life you know what I mean like
it's just like such a strong like when I
get sick with heroin and I'm dope sick I
become so sick that I wish I was dead
sometimes you know like instead of being
sick and I'll do anything to get well
you know I've done some really fucked-up
[ __ ] to make sure that I never got sick
you know you find the line that you're
willing to cross changes is you
definitely versus when I'm have dope and
stuff I'm a lot more in control but when
they I don't have dope and I don't know
where I'm gonna get my next issue or my
next amount of money I you know put
myself in positions that were extremely
and more you know like not what was the
most extreme thing youth the most
extreme thing that I've done is I I had
sex with like two different guys
at the same time and it was just for
like a little tiny piece of like black
you know just like a shot of black that
would only last me like for like an hour
so you know but I was so sick and you
know and they just I just kind of like
you know that it was just one like you
know from the front one from the back
and it was just at the same time and I
was
really roughing you know it was as I let
them like just use my body for whatever
you know and I just was not wanting to
be sick you know and it's something I
regret very much but I just I am not
gonna lie if I had to I would do it
again to make myself not sick because
being sick and feigning for that when
you know that you're so sick and you're
like can't even get up to go to the
bathroom and you're [ __ ] yourself
and you are like just you feel like [ __ ]
you like and you know that one little
piece of dope this like tiny is you know
it doesn't even have to be a lot just a
little tiny bit and you you know put it
back into your veins
and it makes you such completely well
again like every symptom gone and you
can function completely normal like even
better than our normal human like when I
do that dope I don't have no pain I can
go for hours you know walking like I
don't have no no issues with my knees
like I used to you know like all my
pains go away so I can do things that
like I see no like a superhuman and then
so that's probably why would I do get
sick it hurts so bad too because my body
is going so high up with the dope and
then it shoots back down so bad that
it's like one extreme to the other and
it's really you know a tough life to
live really okay would you say to your
family and kids is if they happen to see
this I'm just sorry I really wish that
they would have not turned their back on
me you know because you know I wish it
would have been more patient you know
not just like say you know handle it
yourself because the craziest thing too
is like my drug addiction to opiates
really started you know I don't mean to
like put my mom out there but my mom and
I started using opiates together when I
was just after my first c-section
why we're abusing
the painkillers and stuff and I never
really looked at it as like drug use at
all because we were using painkillers
but my art addiction became so strong
that we were buying 30 milligram pills
off the streets and we were going home
and being like grandma and mom so I
didn't feel it as doing drugs like how
when you smoke crystal or do drugs in
the streets you're out here you know
because when I was doing drugs with my
mom we were always like doing drugs so
we can be a better family you know
because we couldn't function around each
other when we didn't have it so when we
would get height together like it was
you know just super good family time and
my son would be so excited you know
because all of a sudden we'd be high
feeling good and we would be so fun you
know and we get on the ground play and
then when we didn't have the drugs like
my son you know would have to sit and
watch TV while we felt bad you know
however my mom would lay in bed and
stuff or I'd lay in bed and you know
like it was just one extreme to the
other and my mom ended up losing her job
from being a parole officer she had
worked there for 23 years and they found
out because she was showing up so high
every day and carrying a gun so they had
to do it in interviewing you know she
got fired and everything and it was
really hard on the family and so that's
why they blamed me a lot because they
feel like I was the one providing her
from the drugs and when she lost her job
she lost a lot of you know her her
person persona and everything that she
worked for and so the family kind of
blamed that on me and because my mom
after she lost her job she went to rehab
got clean and took the kids when I chose
to keep continuing using drugs I didn't
go to rehab and stuff so I stayed
getting worse and worse
you know while everybody was like trying
to help my mom and my kids and stuff
which I really appreciate more than
anything that they took my kids and took
care of they did so much better than I
could have you know I just I just wished
that I things would have worked out a
little bit different you know huh what
do you think most people that don't do
hard drugs like this don't understand
that
diction the you think that we are like
losers and that we choose to do this a
lot of us are extremely intelligent as
you get like I have my college to create
like I'm extremely intelligent I know
you know a lot of things I just have
issues with like self-esteem depression
you know I'm trying to use these drugs
to not feel like you know I'm sad you
know I would just want to be happy you
know and like be normal but the drugs in
the beginning they made us feel normal
you know but as you go further and
further you don't it doesn't become
normal becomes extremely messed up and
you start to lose your your mind you
know you lose everything your family
your mind I just don't ever do this you
know if you're cool and you don't need
drugs don't do them because once you
start doing and you develop an addiction
you'll have it the rest of your life
even if you become clean so it's not
something you want to get you know right
away thank you so much sharing your
story sorry yeah it's a little bit
emotional sorry I tried to cry
interpretation
you